- [Narrator] Mariachi, defined
by its blaring trumpets,
the rumbling guitarrón, the
singers' inimitable grito.
(singer vocalizing)
And the iconic mariachi suits
known as trajes de charro.
And to find the best
tailor of these trajes,
you have to go east of the LA river,
tucked between the 101 and the 5
in this unassuming
building in Boyle Heights,
where you can find a maestro
de los trajes de charro.
Jorge Tello.
(festive mariachi music)
Believe it or not, this master
of the Mexican tradition
is not even from Mexico.
- Guatemala.
- [Narrator] Guatemala?
(festive mariachi music)
(singer vocalizing)
(quirky music)
First things first.
What's a charro?
(speaking in foreign language)
Jorge's the guy to ask.
Around these parts, he's known
as El Maestro, or The Master.
(speaking in foreign language)
As far as we're concerned,
he's lived up to the name.
For the past 30 years,
Jorge and his sister Sandra
have been customizing, designing,
and sewing these beautiful trajes
for musicians all over the world,
including some celebrities.
(speaking in foreign language)
So many, he can't even remember.
(festive music)
What is it about these trajes
that sets them apart from the rest?
(speaking in foreign language)
And you can't talk about mariachi in LA
without talking about Jorge's
neighborhood of Boyle Heights.
(speaking in foreign language)
(festive mariachi music)
There's no place where this is
more true than mariachi plaza
where you can find mariachis
waiting for their gigs.
Mariachis like Arturo Ramirez.
Arturo, what do you have
to say about Maestro?
(speaking in foreign language)
And there's also Arlette Morales,
whose students are also dressed by Jorge.
(speaking in foreign language)
Jorge, any advice for any
aspiring mariachi out there?
(speaking in foreign language)
Jorge, how much longer do you see yourself
making trajes de charro?
(speaking in foreign language)
How about a grito for the road?
(mariachi vocalizing)